Tucker Carlson the fired Fox News
propagandist has resurfaced for the
first time and made the first statement
since his firing we're going to look at
it it's only a couple of minutes long
the funniest part of it is Tucker
dressed himself up like he still has a
job I don't know why I find that
hilarious uh he's probably wearing
shorts which is fine but he at least at
the top half of his body uh shirt and
tie suit jacket and the entire thing
it's almost like he's doing a monologue
at the top of his show except there's no
show because he's been fired so let's
listen to what he had to say he doesn't
really mention much about the firing
itself it's also funny knowing that he's
doing this from the multi-million dollar
Studio that he put in his house in order
to be able to do Fox News shows from
home
uh it's it's all just endlessly funny
but let's listen really a profile and
courage Tucker Carlson's first statement
since the firing here we go good evening
Carlson one of the first things he he
even starts as if he's still on Fox News
it's it's so good she realized when you
step outside the noise for a few days is
how many genuinely nice people there are
in this country kind and decent people
people who really care about what's true
and a bunch of hilarious people also a
lot of those it's got to be the majority
of the population right the majority of
the population is really really funny
hilarious people also a lot of those
it's got to be the majority of the
population even now so that's heartening
the other thing you notice when you take
a little time off is how unbelievably
stupid most of the debates you see on
television are yes but that
this is so funny he's been fired for
three days and he wants to act like the
biggest critic of the way that
television is produced his Network and
his the programs he's been on for for
decades at this point quite frankly
are the reason why we don't get
substantive debates on for-profit
television we don't get substantive
discussions it's because you've got a
cram in a four minute interview
in between commercials and Lindsey
Graham crying about something like he's
the
it's it's not an incorrect diagnosis but
he's the one who caused the illness in
the first place to a great degree
they're completely irrelevant they mean
nothing true in five years we won't even
remember that we had them trust me as
someone who's participated
and yet at the same time and this is the
amazing thing the undeniably big topics
the ones that will Define our future get
virtually no discussion at all that's
true but that applies to his own program
now I guess now he's saying with the
benefit of hindsight you know I had no
choice they had me over a barrel or
whatever the case may be it's all you've
got to read between the lines but it's a
guy who is responsible for the status
quo
pretending to take the moral High Ground
like he's a victim of it or civil
liberties emerging science demographic
change corporate Power by the way
demographic change means you remember
when he said brown people come in and
make us dirtier and poorer
that's what he's talking about and
trying to whitewash here actual
resources
when was the last time you heard a
legitimate debate about any of those
issues it's been a long time debates
like that are not permitted in American
Media both political parties and their
donors have reached consensus on what
benefits them and they actively collude
to shut down any conversation about it
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party State huh
pressing realization but it's not
permanent our current orthodoxies won't
last they're brain dead nobody actually
believes them hardly anyone's life is
improved by them this moment is too
inherently ridiculous to continue and so
it won't
the people in charge know this that's
why they're hysterical and aggressive
they're afraid
they've given up persuasion they're
resorting to force now I want to make
another Point here and then I will
listen to the last 30 seconds without
another interruption
you as a an informed consumer of media
you know people who listen to my show
it's obviously a self-selected group
it's not random people I know many of
you because you wrote to me and you
responded to my tweets about this video
many of you are confused about what the
hell Tucker Carlson is talking about now
in short he's basically
without directly saying it he's saying
that the Deep state uniparty that
controls Democrats and Republicans has
silenced him because he wanted to talk
about the big issues of our time and
nobody would let him talk about it or
whatever
but understand that if you who follow
all of these different conspiracies and
ideas if you're confused by what the
hell Tucker Carlson is talking about
imagine his audience they don't have a
clue what this is about they it's it's
the the exact type of thing Trump does
where he talks about things no one
really understands because he's
deliberately either con he's either
deliberately obfuscating or confused but
it doesn't matter because it's a cult
that follows him but it won't work when
honest people say what's true calmly and
without embarrassment they become
powerful whoa at the same time the Liars
who've been trying to silence them
shrink and they become weaker that's the
iron law of the universe true things
Prevail doesn't seem like it where can
you still find Americans saying true
things there aren't many places left but
there are some and that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon there you go so now if
you're saying what is that a statement
about the firing it doesn't sound like
it has anything to do with the firing
you have to read between the lines and
so when you read between the lines and
he talks about the uniparty that's
really in power it's not Democrats or
Republicans when he talks about there
are great forces that don't want us to
have the serious conversations we need
to have a lot of what's in the media is
stupid and all these different things
he's essentially saying
um Fox News is part of the problem it's
not about left right there's like some
kind of Greater Elite that is in charge
in controlling everything and they want
to silence me and they want to silence
you and all of these sort of things so
on the Practical matters what is Tucker
Carlson's most likely next stop
I think the most profitable thing would
be his own Venture and hilariously
because of the text messages that were
released as a result of the Dominion
voting systems lawsuit we know that one
of his former producers was actually
engaged in texting with him I believe it
was a producer uh about hey you know
what if we like start our own thing and
we could make this much from the podcast
and we could make this this much from
the website and so on and so forth
particularly at this point in time it
seems to me that Tucker's most
profitable move long term would be to
start his own thing and control all of
the revenue the easier thing and I can
tell you this is someone who I you know
I'm running the entire thing here and
and so on and so forth the easier your
thing although maybe less profitable
would be just to get hired by someone
like would Newsmax hire Tucker they
probably would would it be as profitable
as if he built up his own entity no but
he wouldn't have to worry about any of
that logistical stuff and he could just
talk to the camera and get a paycheck so
I don't know where he will end up but it
does seem the most lucrative option
would be to launch his own thing he's
got a lot of followers and people who
would just send you know people send a
billionaire Trump money because he says
I need money and they don't think twice
about it they will obviously send Tucker
money as well so that's it uh Tucker
Carlson uh you know respectfully getting
dressed up as if he still has a show and
uh delivering a two-minute monologue
about
how I guess everybody else is bad and
he's good and he'll tell you the truth
we will continue to follow the Tucker
Saga we will take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors is betterhelp I am a
huge believer in therapy let's say
you've been thinking for a while about
getting into therapy you know it's the
right move you have things you'd like to
talk to someone about there is no better
time than the present but you don't have
to drive across town every week and sit
in a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists specializing in a wide range
of issues you answer a few questions
about yourself and better help will
match you with a therapist based on your
specific needs and preferences the
sessions can be on the phone video call
chat anytime anywhere from your couch at
home from your office at work and if
your therapist isn't the right fit you
can switch anytime at no charge my
audience gets 10 off your first month at
better help.com slash Pacman the link is
down below